roger points clés christian dior ou
encore joséphine baker lors d'un
concours d'élégance automobile
les photos des frères ces bergers sont
présentés dans l'exposition dans le
studio des frères s'héberger au château
de maisons laffitte des années 1940 à
une centaine d'oeuvres sont exposées des
tirages photos moderne mais aussi des
objets comme des appareils photo des
frères ses berges et des revues et des
documents d'archivés prêtée par la
bibliothèque nationale de france
objectif raconter l'histoire d'une
dynastie familiale de photographe jean
et albert sont deux frères dont le père
et les oncles étaient également
photographe
donc c'est une histoire familiale que
l'on raconte dans cette exposition
histoire d'une dynastie de photographes
français avec une chronologie qui part
en gros du tout début du 19e siècle dans
la première photo de la famille
s'héberger c'est 1898 de jules et
jusqu'en 1977 dans la galerie des
célébrités on peut retrouver des
portraits d'edith piaf luis armstrong ou
encore jean cocteau
c'est vrai qu'ici on sent que les frères
ces bergers ont vraiment réussi à
capturer
à la fois un expression du poète
tourmenté grands créateurs est aussi
l'homme dans son intimité domestique
voilà tout à fait séduisant dans cette
exposition se trouve également une
reconstitution d'un labo avec lumières
rouges épinglés au mur une petite
cinquantaine de photos présentant des
constructions d'autoroutes ou de stade
on y trouve aussi des témoignages de
tous les petits métiers de paris de
l'après-guerre qui ont disparu
progressivement donc artisans de paris
on y trouve aussi des photos de vacances
voilà donc ça permettait de montrer plus
généralement la la diversité de leur
travail photographique pour le château
de maisons laffitte qui date du xviie
siècle
cette exposition permet de diversifier
la programmation culturelle
rendez-vous au sous-sol du château pour
la découvrir jusqu'au 11 octobre